it's like a little bit unbelievable and
we're like a little bit overwhelmed
six-time 2021 nominee dua lipa
is looking to add to her grammy
collection the grammy goes to
jualifa
already honor mantle best new artists
and best
dance recording trophies from 2019
ceremony do you ever take a step back
and just realize that it's only been two
years since you won best new artist and
all that you have accomplished during
that time
i'm so grateful and and you know i feel
like
winning best new artist almost like
pushed me to just like work harder and i
was like all right i gotta prove that i
deserve to be here and
it was just um i've just had such a
blast and so much fun so i'm
so grateful obviously the 25 year old
singer released her sophomore album
future nostalgia in march 2020
right at the start of covid lockdown i
feel like
when i was thinking about you know when
i was going to put this album out and
whether it was the right time i was like
you know what the reason why i did this
was to get away from any
outside pressures and i was like maybe
it is the time to put this out and maybe
it can serve
as that for other people the upbeat
album brought the club to quarantine
with dance hits like physical baby keep
on dancing
[Music]
and levitate i need you
[Music]
the album i guess when i was making it
although i never envisioned something
like this to happen
it did serve for me as like a form of
escapism
i was like trying to shut out anything
that was going on in my life and i just
wanted to have fun
dua set into uncharted territory
promoting an album during a pandemic
and set the standard with her studio
2054
virtual concert an online performance
which is um it's not like the live show
it's more like a
live music video it's quite theatrical
it's um something that i wouldn't be
able to do
on stage so i have this opportunity to
kind of bring this
to fans and she even gave us a remixed
version of the album
featuring collaborations with madonna
gwen stefani
and missy elliott it was amazing such
such a dream come true you know creating
this
remix record with the blessed madonna
was
something that i guess would never have
happened if it wasn't for
you know the pandemic and everyone being
at home and having time to do this
um so i'm so so grateful to all the
artists and
all the producers and um djs and
everybody that kind of took part in this
record to make it so special
now fans are hoping dua can sweep the
major categories at this year's ceremony
future nostalgia is up for album of the
year while don't start now
is up for song of the year and record of
the year don't show
up don't come out
don't start caring about me now
what does it mean to you to be nominated
in what i call like the golden trifecta
like album song um you know like it's a
really top tier and to get the
nominations in that three those three
categories is
incredible i mean it's bonkers really
it's mind-blowing crazy you found out
would you
just like i was no it's just it yeah it
does
take you by surprise and you're just
like this is
it's amazing especially being from the
uk it's just like
and kosovo i'm just like what is
happening like i i don't know i
i these things are things that really
only happen in
in your dreams so i'm i feel like
well i'm hoping no one's going to wake
me up and be like all right time for
school or something